hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to deep space waifu
now hear me out this is
not a game where you go into space
and shoot the clothes off of giant
planet-sized women
that would be weird that's not what
we're doing here
in this game we are shooting the clothes
off of giant planet-sized women
in space uh
okay so the
this game
this game it
all right so i can explain what's
happening here
and i will so you see this it's like mr
massage in terms of the dating app or
any dating app
now there are women
here whoa i don't know what i did
no no no oh
okay so i've got motoko suda
sarah dorner and tomoko aioli
right okay so this
game is like a dating app
except that you uh except that you
are in space shooting the clothes off of
giant planet-sized women
mangaka dream drawing i've been reading
manga since i was born
i may be only 18 but i've read every
manga out there i've eaten manga i've
breathed manga i live for manga daisu
as the queen of the japanese sequential
art aficionados i draw 22 hours a day to
become the best mangaka ever
date bio
[Music]
did i hear that voice or was that the
voice of someone judging me from my
family ghosts stop looking at me
all right so ooh classic power bullet
cleaner
oh bullet cleaner okay all right i got
that slow motion half speed close work
speed run devil double speed and damage
that sounds nice and doesn't have
anything to do with tearing off clothes
waifu the ultimate word of power
all right hear me out guys it's not
this is not a porn game it's a very well
polished
shmup even though the developers refer
to it as a strip
em up that does not mean that it is
bad i'm just gonna go with classic
bullet cleaner
ooh gentleman's mode mouse only mode
super casual oh it's like one hand mode
for lefties
now why would you only need to play with
one hand
i don't know faster gentleman's mode you
want to marry your waifu so you need to
show her that you're the perfect
gentleman
this is the ultimate challenge mode
destroy any part of any clothes
and it's taken over practice get good
and you can truly become her senpai
one hand mode will be disabled
all right so i'm gonna do speed of my
motorcycle oh
hell yeah let's max out that bad boy
joystick dead zone
i don't know what that means but uh
let's slow let's slow her down let's
take it to a nice
you know barry manilow level who is
i don't i didn't use that uh barry white
right okay let's go oh my god
we went in the ocean hi hello
no i'm not excuse me ma'am i'm sorry
why are you huge oh i'm going i'm sorry
i'm going that way apparent why am i
okay all right
well i am on a motorcycle
i am in space i'm shooting i'm shooting
close
it's not what you think mom don't walk
in here
mom i'm sorry it's not what you think it
is guys
so i swear there's this game has depths
and it's got story
and it's got a lot of reasons why i'm
playing it right now
oh geez these nice tootsies
uh anyway
just get you know it's it's cold out in
space you should keep your socks on lady
i got a rocket launcher that sounds very
official and game-like
which is what i'm doing here playing a
game okay
ma'am i'm sorry i should have been
playing on true gentlemen mode
how am i supposed to avoid i got to
shoot the enemies they're kind of in the
way of clothes
oh god i shouldn't be playing this game
there's no excuse for it
ah ah what am i shooting i don't wanna
know
oh what is happening why are you doing
that
is it windy in space oh geez
is there a draft in here or is it just
you
i'm sorry nothing i
say is good get away evildoer
oh i am sorry this is not my intention
lady lady i'm sorry
you are huge and are probably
threatening
you're probably threatening all of
mankind i mean
if we're all to be perfectly honest here
if we all one day
in the night sky looked up and saw a
giant
planet-sized lady anime girl
specifically
smiling down at us we would be very very
scared
so sorry ah you know i'm gonna just go
avoid that this is good not looking at
nothing closer at seven or hello
hi not doing nothing
not doing nothing nope
nope i'm over here now hello that's a
nice star
right there that's a good one okay all
right
sorry sorry sorry sorry
sorry sorry sorry sorry okay this game
is on steam by the way this game is
available on steam
i'm not telling you to get it or nothing
i'm just saying like
for the sake of you know pointing out
certain things this game is about this
game is on steam so it cannot be
super pornographic there's rules and
such
i mean hoonie pop was on steam but you
know that was slightly censored
yeah yeah lady
oh too much intimacy i'm sorry i didn't
mean to celebrate my victory
hello hi hello boss fight indeed
okay hi oh what is that oh i'm sorry oh
no
the bra ma'am i'm sorry i'm not doing
anything i'm just trying to hit the boss
ah i'm sorry is there a put clothes on
button
i'm just trying to hit the i'm dead i'm
just trying to hit the
i'm dead
well maybe that's for the best okay all
right
okay i'm gonna play back to where i was
i don't because just shooting bad guys
nothing weird about that
i'm very sorry about whatever just
happened
oh sorry sorry ma'am oh no okay
well all right okay just gotta get
um nope i'm not gonna shoot that nope
not gonna do it i'm a gentleman
as a gentlemanly game just shooting the
bus well
nope nope nope nope that's not oh that's
not what i'm going for
and i don't want to die again so it's
all good everything's fine nope
sorry nope sorry didn't no don't wanna
that's not why i'm not okay we did it
yay all right we got it
nope nope gonna look over here wow this
is a nice knee
boy oh my god
this is trying to take a picture of the
knee
i'm sorry i'm sorry lady
i'll pay for the damage i caused anyway
nice pillow
all right see ya i'm gonna leave now
girl unlocked great
okay cool really then well we've got a
few
options nice oh you look like yuri from
doki doki literature club
welp mitsumi katagiri
hey there my name is mitsui katagiri i'd
say more about myself
but i only have a five minute break in
my 24 7 study program
after all i must have the best gpas in
the galaxy otherwise my family will
disown me in my very future will be in
jeopardy
and we all know the future is much more
important than parties or fun or life
itself
study misumi study damn you woman study
this profile is meant for study partners
only 24 7 galactic study program to
reach the best
gpas in the galaxy to be the best
student is my dream and i'll use every
single second to study
i'll overcome this challenge and nothing
will stop me if you have any
motivational phrases stuff please link
them to me
tks okay all right
square roots round roots test test says
lucky school attire pop quiz help me a
plus only five more years senpai i sleep
at school with the ultimate student okay
all right well all right let's do a
super casual the super cash
okay all right this is a good game this
is a good game guys
hi hello you are gigantic why are you
here
why are you oh i'm sorry i'm not what
what are you on ah i am sorry
i'm not looking i i'm not looking i
swear i'm sorry i'm sad
it's drafty in here ah i'm not looking i
swear to god i'm so sorry
i'm sorry everybody watching i'm sorry
everybody at home i'm sorry everybody
i'm sorry for everything i'm sorry for
recording this video
i'm sorry i'm sorry you have to die i
don't know what's happening here
or why all i know is that everybody has
to die because i like shmups i do
oh i'm so sorry i'm so you got a face on
your butt yeah
i'm sorry i noticed that study study
study indeed
why are you why are you 10 miles tall
oh no i'm sorry i'm i'm sorry i'm sorry
ah i feel bad okay stop senpai
all right i'm sorry i'm sorry i never
take my glasses off
okay so
sorry mmm so intimate sorry
sorry sorry excuse me sorry nope not
shooting that sorry
sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry i'm sorry
i'm very sorry
oh what is this
okay i used my bam i used my i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry
i'm sorry oh i don't like that i don't
like that at all
okay got it nailed it nailed it okay all
right okay
all right here we go here we go there we
go there we go got it
okay all right did it okay all right
you're not naked
great that's a plus in my book
take a nice picture of this knee nice
knee real nice knee there we go
whoops not what i hadn't ended all right
see ya okay thank you
why are you reading weeb mag okay all
right girl unlocked great is that a
yandere
unlock the yandere girl
yep that is the yandere girl all right
yumi matsuda okay aren't you cute
you're so cute it makes me feel like
ripping your eyes out i think i already
love you and if anybody tries to get in
the way
i'll strangle them with their own bloody
guts
why do i need their blood type knives
strings
violence rip your heart out torture love
you cut you to pieces pain you won't
leave stay forever
okay it's a good game this is a good
game i feel good about this
hi yep sure am ah yep
i am okay hello hi why are you sleeping
why is giant space lady sleeping i'm
sorry
can someone please count how many times
i've said i'm sorry in this game
i'm very sorry i do not mean to do that
i'm sorry
i'm very sorry i'm sorry nice tootsies
why do you have blood on your socks
that's what i don't know oh okay
well then you don't have socks my
mistake
oh hello hi what the hell was that
what the hell ow okay i'm dead
apparently okay this is actually getting
difficult i have to focus on this one
i'm a good at schmubs
i'm a goodich mups
hi hello how are you doing oh very sorry
about that
ah too intimate i agree if you could
back up a little bit
that'd be great i know you're sorry
sorry i didn't know what i was shooting
at
very sorry about that ooh sorry sorry
sorry
sorry ah nope not not what i'm shooting
at
nope all right okay all right
fine fine fine fine fine i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm very oh okay
hey there we go all right we're all good
[Music]
nope nope nope sorry oh boy all right
all right geez it can't be like it can't
actually be
it can't actually be like
it's got to be censored right that's
that's my thing right
to live life in the fullest you must
make the best of the time you have as
such there are two hours for my date
on my daily schedule after that you have
30 minutes to take me home
further activities can be conducted on
tuesdays and fridays at 9
10. any delays will be noted three
delays and you're out life is scheduled
the universe is scheduled you are
scheduled boy
so i'll give it straight you want to do
this you have two hours to get me
30 minutes to take me home further
activities can be conducted on tuesdays
and fridays from 9 to 10 p.m
the time for this message is over okay
all right whatever you say why are these
giant body pillows in space
i don't understand where i'm i'm going
i'm getting your heel a tickle tickle oh
who's got a tickly shin oh you do here
we go
oh who's got a shin the size of long
island you do
oh you've got legs that go on for
literally infinity
ah oh i'm sorry i was aiming for your
legs i don't know what happened to your
skirt
hey look listen listen lady listen
i've played a lot of hoonie pop in my
day i know
all about how to flirt properly with the
ladies
and shooting them with lasers while
you're in space
and they're gigantic is way up high on
that list
let me tell you something oh that was a
lot of points
listen okay all right i am sorry
ah you know i just
you know i like my ladies strong
i just don't know if if i like him to be
able to pla
crack a planet in half you know what i
mean
i don't know i don't know i don't know
what it means i mean i'm not short or
nothing but i feel kind of small
this juncture too much intimacy you know
i'd kind of agree with that one oh
oh oh jeez it's got to be censored right
got to be oh my god oh
i'm so sorry i didn't i i didn't mean it
oh god i'm sorry i'm sorry i am sorry
i am very sorry i am sorry ah
i'm very very sorry all right berries
all right oh geez
oh geez okay all right cool
great oh jeez oh geez
oh geez scoop oh geez oh gee oh geez
oh geez i am sorry i'm sorry
i am sorry i'm sorry there's a bomb i'm
sorry
did i mention oh sorry i am i am sorry i
am dodging
oh hey whoo i am sorry
her garbage sense
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry
i'm not looking you're not looking we're
not looking i am not looking
i'm not looking i'm not looking i'm not
looking
i am not looking i am sorry i'm sorry
i'm sorry
i am sorry i am sorry i am sorry i'm
sorry
i didn't mean that i am sorry i'm
putting the game down
i'm sorry anyway that was deep space
waifu i think i'm done for now
thank you everybody so much for watching
i'm
sorry
please let me know what you think down
the comments below i will not provide a
link to this game in the description i
guess i should out of all fairness and
team did work hard on it but at the same
time
this game is also i i should point out
this game is
overwhelmingly positively rated by the
way
hey i can't i can't imagine why these
giant planet-sized girls you know
if i if we saw a giant planet-sized girl
i'd like to think i'm not trying to rip
their clothes off
i'm just trying to kill them in whatever
way i can and their clothes are their
only weak point
i guess anyway so thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
thought down in the comments below
and as always i will see you in the next
video
[Music]
bye-bye